this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the Marv triangle in Kenya there is a
male leopard just walking behind that
bush my name is Steve joined by big
James on camera and we are so excited to
have you here let's just go back to him
he's over there he's been walking and
walking and walking we've been with him
for about two hours there he is
believe him to be the ship it's tree
mail we just had the most amazing two
shot of him with a giraffe and elephant
behind and anyway he is walking very far
the wind is in his face and he's looking
at a buffalo a moment ago but the
Buffalo is way too big for you boy
he is definitely on the hunt he's been
doing lots of scent marking and spraying
oh there's a warthog just over here
James he hasn't seen it that is what
he's been smelling there's a water over
here at 11 o'clock he has been trying to
sniff out of this warthog I think for
the longest time everybody remember we
are live and interactive we'd love to
hear from you hashtag safari live on
Twitter or throw your questions in on
the YouTube chat stream he has been
going from mound to mound from Bush to
Bush trying to search for something and
I've finally seen another animal that is
not an elephant let her off or a buffalo
I think Emma I think he might have
spotted that a warthog so if you would
like to invite some more people on board
let's go for it I've lost sight of this
warthog but the male is yeah he has an
idea he has an idea he's just there he
spotted it he's going to go into full
stalk mode
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
Mara triangle in Kenya where we have got
a male leopard my name is Steve I'm
joined by James but Mikey back over to
the action
he has just spotted a warthog
he has been we've been walking with him
for the longest time and there's a
warthog just off to the left that it
looks like an absolute beast it's got
its back to him if you have any
questions or comments throw them in
below we are in the Mara Triangle in
Kenya this we believe to be the ship its
tree mail I think he spotted the warthog
he's giving it a very good look but I
think he might be a bit intimidated by
the fact that it is from what I can see
a pretty decent sized male so anyone he
is probably about 35 40 yards okay
the warthogs slowly moving he's going to
go into stalk mode you can see how long
this grass has has been a very tricky
trying to keep up with him as we've been
moving through this long grass and we
haven't seen another animal apart from
elephants giraffe and Buffalo which are
taller then of the Cross hello Janet yes
I do believe it's the shippers tree mail
was identified by a few of the other
guides in the area I've never seen it
before so I'm going on the judgment the
other guards have given me and he is a
very relaxed he's been walking past the
car he's been sent marking hasn't made a
sound but he's definitely keen on some
bacon I think this afternoon so let's
just keep on him there the warthog I'm
not sure where it's gone now there might
be a burrow there there might be a mud
wallet but by what I could see on the
side of the face they were at least two
sets of warts which indicates a male now
a big male warthog is a formidable
opponent so he might be looking to see
if there's any other little youngsters
with the Warthog I'm not going to move
gonna stay right yet because we don't
want to influence either the Warthog or
him I don't think the warthog knows that
he is here Nicole this is very beautiful
exciting he's been giving us such
wonderful shots we've been waiting to go
live on on the actual afternoon show and
all of a sudden as we went live so we
went live again he's moving forward you
can see how he's going through the
typical leopard crawl everybody that is
where they get where we all get the term
leopard crawl from the ability to get a
very low to the ground
Rosalind I'm having another look now and
I don't think it's more than about 28 to
30 meters or 30 yards at the most and
he's covering that slowly as we watch
now we don't want to go any closer as I
said because the starting our engine the
movement we've been very patient with
him as he has been very patient looking
for food and this is his first
opportunity that we have seen so we
don't want to get involved and influence
it anyway but he has disappeared into
the long grass this I just need to get a
little bit more of an angle
okay I can see here is just below the
end of that green bush James so now we
can't see a very good view of him but
this is the way it works everybody I've
done this once before we were aimed a
camera at a leopard looking into a
warthog hole for an hour and 50 minutes
he's just off a little bit left now
James James can't see him he's got very
flat everybody okay I think I might just
move up half a meter just so that we can
get him in view again not gonna go too
close areas there
okay there we go he got him James misses
the cross is extremely long I've been
hoping her not gonna fall in a hole but
I think this is exactly what he's been
looking for bye everybody we can't see
him I've just got a view of him moving
through but the Warthog there are
boroughs around here there are lots of
boroughs around yet so this is what he's
been looking for I think we just give
this another moment Dermer he's really
sneaking up there there's a big termite
mound a borough just next to me on my
left indicating that there's definitely
water diggings around I know it's not
very attractive everybody looking in to
long grass like that Joe well when
you've got camouflage like a leopard s
and you've got this sort of cover well
I'd hate to be a warthog I'd hate to be
any of these small animals that are
trying to hide away but I think he's
completely flat I'm just gonna try get
another little view here in visible
hobbie there's a number of things that
might warn the Warthog other warthogs
birds off in the distance there's some
Eiland and Buffalo running but just over
here next this hole I can just see the
ears of a warthog I think it's got its
body in the ground
generally it's quite tricky because
there's been hardly any animals around
sometimes you do find oxpeckers on
warthogs and they could fly off an alarm
but warthogs would respond so James just
here at my one o'clock there's a
warthogs is there and the leopard last
time I saw is not far away at all James
can't quite see it you see my line here
in last I saw that leopard was getting
closer and closer this could go either
way everybody you can see the warthogs
ears there
Clare it is I think it's facing us and I
think that that limit is just behind the
bush
okay I'm gonna give it one more meter
forward one more meter just to maybe get
this ship it's Gmail into shot see the
Warthog to me look like it just had its
bottom in the hole and was just sort of
chilling out really didn't look like it
was doing much wasn't even eating it's
just sort of hanging out there there's a
lot of digging over there so we can see
the Warthog now warthog is too clear
over my shoulder now and the male
leopard is done okay I can see him he's
just in front of the screen Bush over
there on the right James as the warthog
and a leopard is at my two and a half
just in front of that green bush and he
hasn't moved from where we saw him
before when he's looking directly a
little bit more right James a little bit
more right and there he is in the middle
to the right of the screen
now that is leopard camouflage and
Christine
it is indeed the master disguise so he
is probably about 20 yards right now as
we speak and he's being very patient
we've been with him for about two hours
following him and this is the first real
attempt he's had at any meal he's been
smelling and sniffing and no doubt he's
been picking up the scent of all sorts
of creatures along the way
and we were with him he finally stopped
on the bush not far from where we are
now and he suddenly picked up his ears
and he started moving off in this
direction at quite a pace and it's only
then that we finally saw the warthog who
is doing a very good job of remaining
camouflaged as well now for safety
warthogs do go down in to their burrows
and if they do go down I have seen
leopards dig them hard before it is
quite an interesting thing to see
obviously a water goes in backwards so
it has the potential to come out with
it's very dangerous tasks or dashes and
can definitely do some damage to all
sorts of animals trying to go in Fran
well the number one warthogs are very
quick and very fast and they run away
and they also can turn and they have big
tasks not just these ones but the ones
underneath that sort of sharp and on the
big tasks those things are extremely
dangerous and they'll run out to a halt
and reverse in backwards if anything's
trying to come and dig them out they can
come out and those tasks can to be
absolutely lethal to not just a leopard
a lion to anybody we even on trails
walks you got to be very careful walking
in front of a warthog burrow okay well I
can still see him in the long grass he's
looking directly at the warthog the
warthogs picked his head up a little bit
more I think he is maybe wondering
whether he could get closer
Joel what we've noticed is he's been
following a smell he's been definitely
sniffing absolutely ever oh he's been
going for the most of the time he's been
invisible in the grass but whenever he's
had an opportunity he's climbed up onto
a termite mound and he's had a little
bit of a look and every time he's done
that we've had a look and it was only
just recently that something got his
attention
and we don't know what it was he might
have heard a pigs noise he might have
picked up on a very strong smell but
looking at him he is looking intently
towards and that warthog but he's not
moving he's probably trying to weigh up
the longer he waits the more relaxed a
warthog in the war took family would
become and maybe that even come out of
the hole and start moving around and if
they started moving around that might
make them a little bit easier to catch
well everybody we're gonna close it
there for now but that is awesome we're
gonna sit right here we're gonna see how
this plays out who knows the leopard or
the warthog who could win this battle
well everybody what a way to start the
afternoon and we're gonna stay right
here with this war talk and see if we
can get a proper look at the size of him
and maybe that's why the shippers chu
man is being so sort of hesitant and
while we wait sure and sum up the
situation and let's send you down south
to GG for his introduction
hello hello and jumbo jumbo everybody
and how exciting we'll start to see that
leopard hunting well I'm just hoping I
would be able to be lucky and see some
lions hunting because I'm already in the
sausage republic and what you consider I
think human who are those buffaloes
which out guess that's the only food
left
currently for this sauce it is now after
taken every point every vantage point
every high ground
does he even be lucky like Steve and see
the pride of lions that I love very much
this is where they live this is their
territory and very exacting to have all
of you on boards welcome to the other
side of the Mara my name is David and
I'm comin ease man oh man where were you
and you're very hopeful that you are
going to see the sausages because this
day tunes that have given us a piece and
hopefully we are going to see them now
definitely Steve already told you what
we need to do to keep chatting
hashtag Nassif I live on Twitter that is
it should you have any questions any
comments anybody want to know how King
still is doing the last I saw her 48
days ago she was doing perfectly well
now anywhere in that grass that you see
there that's what Kings Hill should be
I'm not sure exactly where but I'm doing
everything possible to see that I'll
smoke her out all right no it's the
difference one big difference between
the Mara Savannah and Juma is the
vegetation have clear savannas here very
open land and my friend Sydney is trying
to scrounge some thickets and he would
like to say hello to all of you a good
afternoon and welcome on board this is
Sydney for Maroney
Miko see Adam travelling with Jean Rey
who is my camera operator this afternoon
we are specifically looking for the
spotted cat and for in case if you need
our attention you can follow us on
Twitter hashtag suffering our
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream I am just checking for the cat's
here
I'm heading towards the tree house damn
area on the ground here the evidence are
very much old I am not seeing any of the
fresh tracks yet so these cats are
hiding
this afternoon I am not going to leave
any stone unturned I will be
investigating each and every warning
call so now let's go to Jamie who is
also on a search for something
interesting
I am I am I am on the search a very good
afternoon to you all and welcome to the
sunset Safari all they were quite far in
at this point my name is Jaime and this
afternoon
Craig is behind the camera and as you
know of course we have our s ABC TV show
and for some reason today is just one of
those days where the cats have gone into
hiding and my plan for the afternoon is
to go on to Chitra right everything else
has failed so I'm gonna go on to I'm
gonna see if I can get hold of Dylan Leo
Smith and find out what's happening
around this area and then for tonight
I'll probably pop back to the hyena den
once we've figured out where everything
is so that for now is the plan of action
and we'll see how that all plays out as
you know when we go to this of the
eastern side we struggle a little bit
with radio comms so if you see me
stopping in mid-sentence in my mouth
dropping open it's because I'm trying to
make head or tail of whatever they're
saying on the radio that's what I'm
going to do now as I'm going to switch
crossing to the east are the Inca
Hummers pulled a sneaky maneuver on us
no man there then coomer's pulled a
sneaky maneuver on us last night last
night there when you're Sydney's down I
don't know if you remember watching on
the sunsets fire yesterday I said
hopefully they will come south during
the night and pop their bottoms down on
Juma they didn't they went all the way
east and popped their bottoms down on
Torchwood and it just so happens that
it's it's a time when we cannot drive
Torchwood we can't when allowed on to
tortured when there's people there it's
long complicated process so they weren't
there instead highly inconvenient for us
but probably quite convenient for them
presumably there's a reason that they
went there now when we go on to choose
where we of costs are looking for
kochava
for Tsuboi occasionally and sometimes
even tin ghana actually
okay all right well thank goodness for
the Mara crew they've been working hard
all afternoon
and they have been thoroughly rewarded
thanks Jaime good luck down south they
and the new comers they are sneaky like
that aren't there
well you can maybe just make out in the
middle of the picture some spots
now that is our male leopard he is flat
in the grass and the warthog that we
were looking at it's not moved I think
it's sort of semi in the ground what
might even be sort of in a mud wallow
I'm not sure but it's not doing much
there it's just sort of lying down I saw
and yesterday I was doing something
similar this whole body was in the sort
of hold on the ground I was just the
face sticking out so they feel probably
a little bit more protected knowing that
they are AMPAS somewhere safe
and well judging by the distance
knowledge we've come a little bit more
to the side probably looking at about 17
yards and there is a little bit of wind
so you would think maybe this male would
try and sneak up a little bit closer
using the cover that he has he's got
lots of calves again he's even got a
little bit of a termite mound with a
bush in front of him so you might be
able to sneak out before Kevin you wanna
know how I avoid being attacked by big
cats well first of all be cats for the
most part are afraid of humans so that
is a very lucky thing that we have it's
an evolutionary sort of code that I have
imprinted printed in their brains that
by daytime cats are afraid of humans
because honor this landscape exactly
where we are looking this is where man
took a sort of liking to meat
and we started chasing and competing
with lions and leopards and the like for
their kills and so for a very very long
time on the African continent through
human evolution cats are afraid of
humans by daytime so for example and
I've had to do it many times in the past
not many times but a few times lions are
invariably afraid of you so once there
was a poaching incident that Lions were
eating the Rhino that was poached and I
had to get them away so that there could
be an investigation and I just drove
towards the scene and opened my door
steps out the Lions or ran away
okay the warthog is at the Lions all ran
away from me it was quite crazy to see a
big pride of lions or suddenly becoming
extremely afraid there's a big male
warthog okay everybody watch very
closely now as he starts feeding and he
starts walking around he's going to the
exact side with us male impetus and male
leopard would probably go as close as he
can but knowing now and that the
warthogs coming towards him this this
could be very interesting okay now bear
in mind at those big touches on that
warthog are very very dangerous
he is facing directly towards probably
one of the largest male leopards I've
come across he is a fantastic specimen
and one day I'll leave my camera at home
are you ready everybody three two one
he's about two meters
he's right there this is about to happen
he's that leopard is right there about
two meters to his right behind his
bottom I think the leopards have been
worried about the size of this guy my
heart is in my mouth quickly all sent
through a one-word tweet how does this
make you feel exhilarating his mind
my width at Lepidus Rodney
he's gotten even flatter than he was
before
see him anymore
now this should be the driving force
behind the attack a leopard would go for
the shoulder of the animal why hasn't
moved I think he's maybe become quite
intimidated by the size after I just
talked him up about being a very big
leopard Wow
sure why not Emma a leopard is
disappeared in the grass there
I think his opportunity has come and
he's turned it down
I can't see him at all this is
ridiculous I was just asking James if
he's ever seen a leopard kill before he
said yes he saw this male leopard kill
an eland okay everybody
hello everybody and welcome back you
know with our male leopard once again
and there's a very big warthog has moved
straight out of the hole directly
towards him and he didn't do anything
we don't quite know why he hasn't made
any decision I think the big male war
talk started walking towards him and he
got a little bit of a fright about the
actual size still cm is still in the
exact same spot as flat as can be he was
honestly about a metre in a yard and a
half from the warthog a moment ago and
he didn't do anything I think he's still
waiting for maybe some others to come
out of the hole now he's in there as
flat in the ground as possibly can get
if you have any questions or comments
please throw them in below coming to you
live from the Mara Triangle in Kenya and
my name is Steve joined about James and
many of you are wondering maybe the wind
revealed him well the wind is blowing
towards him he's in the grass the water
walked towards him
look there so look that when they turned
around and put his bottom right towards
him and nothing happened I'm gonna move
up just another meter yet see if maybe
we can actually see what this lip is
doing last I saw he was flat in the
grass maybe counting his luck that the
warthog didn't actually do anything
towards him
just the term up Mount on the right side
check ok he spotted the Warthog spotted
him everybody there he is the Warthog
suddenly realized he was there the
entire time that leopard had an
opportunity I think and he's looking at
this hole still he is wondering are
there any more war talks coming out look
at that water behind him he is a beast
and those tasks are really really
dangerous I think it would have taken
everything in this leopards strength to
try and pull this warthog down you'll
see the warthogs not even afraid is not
even afraid you can just see how close
that leopard has been this entire time
hello everybody we're having some
technical internet issues I'm afraid so
those of you still live with us on the
show how interesting is that look how
close that leopard was the whole time he
didn't do anything I think it's one of
those doesn't want to bite off more than
he can choose situations that warthog
has not left he is still here and he
might even try and chase that leopard
you know I've seen female warthogs turn
to save that their piglets before
against a lioness or a leopard and often
it lead leads to them getting caught but
a big male warthog like that is only
really got to worry about lions to be
honest Wow you see how then leopard is
playing the aloof game he thinks there's
more Peaks coming out that's what he
thinks he can probably smell them mrs.
Anna they are friends I doubt that they
I doubt that though but he is a big male
leopard and that is a very big wart talk
Lorna you you keyed my one rode tweet
there's well exhilarating is so exactly
what I was feeling and what an excellent
word an excellent way to start this
afternoon not for a warthog family but
um that is working out well for this guy
so far now the warthog walked around he
Jen had she said no fracking with the -
deed now this warthog walked around this
bush and he walked straight past the
leopard the leopard didn't do anything
that's what it amazes me he walked
around that bush on the right so he came
from the front of this mound he walked
around the bush in there I he walked
straight past the mayor lit but turned
his shoulder and everything and the male
leopard stilted and do anything which
just goes to show that the presence of
tasks the presence of some sort of
device on an animal is
even a good-enough deterrent and also
obviously sighs couldn't have to turn to
to protect something from a predator
give it that moment of hesitation and
even though the Warthog had its back to
him perfectly keyed up to be taken he's
coming back this is proper Pumbaa this
one Oh watch out everybody word okay
well that warthog nearly got another
goat but I think he knows the leopard
staying around to look after his family
and he is trying to give him a hard time
okay well you're not gonna go anyway
everybody are we gonna stay right yet
with the action they send you down to
zoom and so they forget with the Sydney
who's got himself a torture off what a
beautiful shot and thank you for that
yandere look at that we have got the
giraffe at the moment here and this
giraffe is trying to be selective as I
could see that some of the trees already
they are starting to dry the leaves and
he is now concentrating on what is
called a buffalo thorn a buffer a thorn
is one of the thorn trees but this
giraffe is not worried about the amount
of thorns or caring by that tree you can
see he is just busy taking off all the
leaves and you can even see some of the
phones they're showing from a distance
so the tongue of the giraffe is very
sticky and his good lot of saliva which
helps them in order to prevent this kind
of thorns as the thorns can also be
dangerous to their tongues so if this
giraffe shows us his tongue you will see
the tongue is much more dark so that
they can also avoid the sunlight as they
are feeding to prevent sunburn the
colour of the tongue is much darker
so the tree this giraffe is feeding on
the buffalo thorn is one of those trees
which are also very much medicinal used
here at the moment we have got only one
which is the one we are seeing we don't
have the two species of giraffe this is
the only type of giraffe we are having
at the moment so if you can check this
giraffe is looking very much dark and
one of the difference between the male
and the female giraffes is the Acala the
giraffes the males they have got dark
spots the females they've got large
spots but both men and females as they
are getting old
they both dominant dark spots which
means when they are both old you must
have to find an alternative way in order
to distinguish between the two here
comes a simple way you must have to
check on top of their Aqsa cones the
males they are bald the females they
have got hairs you can see they're on
top of their horns which are called the
Aqsa cones you can see this no hairs
there if it's a female you will see some
hairs there and the females they've got
very thin oxy cones the males have got
very thick Aqsa cones if you can check
between the the ears there is something
more like another pair of oxic Owens
coming out that is what is called
calcium pockets is where this giraffe is
storing the calcium in order to survive
so now let a cross over back to the
Maasai Mara
where Steve is waiting everybody this is
incredible stuff that male warthog has
come all the way around again
the Shepherd's Chi male you've just
missed him he's gone in to the hole
which is there in the bottom of the
screen the mound ramps up and the hole
is on the other side of the mound so
there is the ramp and just on the other
side of the ramp you might have just
seen his tail as he disappeared now it's
not uncommon we've seen it in Ghana
going to termite mounds
I've never seen it seen him emerge with
anything but this could potentially be
very dangerous for him because dad is on
his way back and well dad is a
formidable looking gentleman well how
incredible is this I've never seen
myself in the flesh a male leopard oil
eppard itself got into water on whole
I've seen countless times them taking
warthogs on the periphery of the den of
the halt but going in like this just
goes to show and if he comes out he's
probably gonna come out either
face-first or backwards with a piglet in
his mouth now to be able to go in there
and turn around just goes to show how
big the extremities are inside they're
huge cavernous extremities it's allowing
more than one warthog to survive just
can't you just keep quiet for a moment
and see the water is actually busy
sniffing the ground where the leopard
was is he gonna be lucky
I'd forget everyone we are live love to
hear for me Cynthia questions and
comments has take Safari live as he is
one task is a little bit worn down it's
very tentative I know that if this is
something everybody's watching very
closely now how long can that male lipid
is stay underground for I wonder if the
water can hear some movement I mean what
do you do if you're war talk in this
situation to go in I don't even know how
to go in face-first hmm
I have no idea how deep it is but let's
see what happens if he comes around
face-first then he's been able to
physically turn his body inside me if
there's more warthogs inside then who
knows I mean they often say with the
large termite mounds or the big fungus
grain so Matt Barnes you fan down in
South Africa there's one field above the
ground in two-thirds below but they're
not that large arch here above ground
but I have no doubt that they're
enormous underground how big exactly is
very hard to say very very hard to say
this is very cool stuff James gnar
sitting here on the edge of that seats
I'm almost shaking in a way here he
comes here comes here comes
empty-handed look of disappointment or
Aarthi what an amazing too shots Jam say
well he went underground for some
shopping but he came out with nothing
a Shana this is indeed very interesting
I mean leopards are also known to dig
and to actually go into the mound itself
to dig out a war target is dangerous
affair but it seems like he's gone in
and he's investigated either there are
no more warthogs in there or he doesn't
know how to dig Haley I was listening
very closely to see if I could hear any
squeals but nothing really made any
impression on me I mean that male water
came around as if he heard something but
then it was just at the bottom of the
ship as female coming back yards again
well boy it's much cooler now than it
was when we started following you are
you a little bit annoyed now he's
licking his lips okay why does he
spotted in the distance now so everybody
it just goes to show the big male lipid
store has met his match when it comes to
a big warthog all talk is still very
very closely watching and well today is
the day of the prey animal
okay everybody well we've been following
him and we'll continue to follow him for
the rest of the afternoon and while we
do that let's go down to Jim up then
where James is getting ready to get to
the drone in the sky hello everybody and
welcome to this end of the sunset Safari
my name is James Henry
and on camera we have got Sebastian on
beanie there he is fantastic we also
have Beatrice given her a new name don't
know why you've been utterly useless
over the last few days haven't found
anything with her at all and today is no
exception we are of course desperately
trying to find cats on account of the
fact that we have a TV show to prepare
for and we don't want to do just driving
around in the pitch-black darkness the
duration of our TV show so we are
attempting valiantly well I think it's
fairly valiant to find some lipids I
haven't found a track we've heard a few
birds alarming we've checked there they
seem to be fighting with each other and
so I think the leopards are having a
really pleasant Sunday afternoon Jamie's
gone find out what's going on chitra I
haven't heard anything on the radio
which is slightly worrying and as soon
as you've seen is also nothing about
trying to find some form of predator
that we can put on camera for our TV
shows so the moment the pressure is
really on darlin arty stuff in the Mara
we've got one leopard in some very thick
grass David back in the sausage Republic
but no sausages at the moment so while
one doesn't want to paint a bleak
picture of the Sunday afternoon and it's
inevitable passing into Sunday evening
in the SABC TV show we are under the
cosh as it were so if you could keep
your eyes on the damn cam make sure we
don't miss anything there send us your
ideas for where you think the animals
are and we'll do our best to find them
wonderful I believe that Sydney's having
a break in cats
I don't know how wonderful it is but
from your point of view it will be
wonderful
I am still here with the giraffe who is
still busy dominating the Buffalo thorn
you can see this giraffe is stationary
feeding at the moment and apologies for
the breakings of some of the pictures or
any related technical problems you can
see this giraffe how is feeding males
normally they feed from the top and if
you can check the females they've got a
little bit of a slight different feeding
behavior they profess to bend their neck
and if you can check on the neck of this
giraffe there is a an open space there
where is hairless that is the skin we
are seeing there giraffes how they fight
is interesting they strangle their necks
and that is where normally the Aqsa cone
of the opponent eat when they strangle
so that is why they don't have as their
so I am sure that was as a result of a
fight but looking at this giraffe I can
see he is very much old so he might have
been engaged on quite a lot of
Fighting's before if you look behind the
neck there is a line of hairs going down
a very beautiful hairs that line of has
it can be a very good indicator of the
level of calcium in the body this line
of s you can use it as a gauge when the
giraffe is leaking calcium this line of
has flattens when this line of s is flat
it means you must then go around the
felt and look for the bones of the other
old dead animals and shoo them in order
to regain some calcium that is a certain
kind of behavior which is called an
osteopathic behavior osteo has got
something to do with feeding on bones
yeah this giraffe it looks very much old
but something we have to check is that
this animals if we can check their life
expectancy not all these animals reach
their life expectancy due to some
predation purposes and some of them they
exceed life expectancies due to quite a
lot of environmental factors when the
food is abandoned
and enough for this animals to feed
sometimes good nutrition gives them an
opportunity to survive much longer but
if there's quite a lot of challenges as
a result of drought we lose these
animals before they even reach the
lifespan so the giraffes can be able to
survive for above 20 years some of them
can get up to 27 years when the
conditions are very good you can see
that this giraffe he doesn't want to
spend much time facing down while we are
waiting
who is gonna come and join the giraffe
by these trees let's cross over to David
by the Maasai Mara interesting to have a
giraffe but I can tell you I have seen a
few giraffes I have seen a few elephants
and a couple of zebras as well but I
have not stopped for either of us
because I have a mission I have a plan
and as I said earlier my plan is to look
for the sausages and yesterday I was
very close to getting them to an area
where a friend of mine had told me I'd
seen them before I got there
huge storm came but you know meters even
power down both the flaps down but today
I have not seen any sign of rain other
words even smelling any clouds that
could give us Rays today so I'll have no
excuse of not getting the sausages this
Sunday afternoon
one thing I've said we cannot hide here
or cannot hide the elephant's you know
regardless of how long the grass is as
Steve or saying
with a jar with the Shepherd female
elephants will not be able to hide and
many fun for wish me all the sausages
because we need to see those cups and I
said a few weeks ago if they hunt every
10 days every 9 the tenth day the Lord's
hundred eight nine at most the eleventh
day the loaders hunt don't be surprised
whatever they are now they have hunted
the last I saw them 42 hours ago
they're going up on a hill and not sure
where they were going because when they
lost chuckling my vehicle was take like
this 45 degrees climbing a hill and
since then they have gone missing
do not say very long update tickets
cause it also won't come down in in an
open area so we have very good chances
of supporting them so let's go back
first to Steve I will he separate a tree
mail
thanks Gigi and while other Shepherds
treemail has just claimed the Shepherd's
tree right there and we continuing to
follow him and he's still walking with
the wind in his face I know many people
have told me that leopards and lions
don't hunt at the winter well we have
been with him for almost three and a
three hours now and while he most
certainly is using the wind and whenever
he possibly can a little bit of elevated
ground like what he's got now he is
magnificent
he's right here next to the cart
probably two and a half three three
yards from us he is our level with me
and one guy I have a look at us show
everybody what a beautiful face you have
he is a beautiful male leopard isn't he
he's drooling a little bit he thought he
had something back there he thought he
secured himself a meal he's putting in a
lot of effort this afternoon we've
walked with him for probably about four
kilometers maybe more and it's hard to
say really art in this open Vista
gorgeous
if he's right here he's right yeah there
anything I'm glad about he's not using
our vehicle for an elevator to purge had
every single sort of prominent termite
mound that is around he most certainly
is you can see the intention in his gaze
every time he's sort of using his mouth
like that he's thinking and then
whenever he sort of stops in his mouth
closes like that and then it stops again
there's a moment of concentration you
see it with lions as well you can almost
tell when they've spotted something the
mouth closes for some reason I don't
know what it is exit to the stage right
well there isn't here magnificent fellow
he's super relaxed he's like a Juma
leopard now I've seen two leopards here
before most likely the same female as
last year sort of they around what we
call hammock or nest on our way back to
camp that one was with Jamie we actually
stopped to have a look at some hammock
ops building a nest and so we turned the
vehicle around to have a look at the
nest and then the hammer cops are going
crazy by the road and out of the grass
jump this female leopard she was not
very relaxed we had a moment with her
some of you might remember that was last
year around the binge series so probably
about February or so last year and then
during that time manizales on my way
back from an evening game drive and I
spotted another leopard in exactly the
same sort of area so I assumed at the
time
it was the same female it was definitely
a girl and she was trotting along away
from me so not like the juma leopards or
like this guy who are completely
habituated to cars and so surprising I
mean you have a look at this Vista that
we're moving through here how are you
supposed to find a leopard in this
longer ice
if James shows you as he walks past us
you know if you're driving along how are
you gonna see that that's just not
possible
we need James Henry up here with
Sebastian to fly the drone to make this
a little bit
he spotted this Buffalo again James you
see how his mouths gone closed everybody
because he's now deciding is it worth
the risk is it worth the risk before we
send you down to South Africa let's just
have a look at this male Buffalo that
he's looking directly at the Buffalo is
going male leopard I will sort you out
you're afraid of a warthog you should be
afraid of me but anyway we're gonna stay
with this male let's quickly send you
all the way back down to say good
afternoon to Jamie well I mean if this
Falls somewhat flat now that it's gone
basically just looks like I really am
taking a break and just kicking back
relax feet up it was exactly what I
think Craig and I should do because
today is not all day we had the cutest
little pearl spotted owl sitting on the
edge of a branch looking grumpy as they
always do and then of course Murphy's
Law I can't god I nearly drove on there
don't do that cuz if he's in this marula
tree somewhere nearly nearly nearly
drove onto an area I can't
oh sorry everyone it was beautiful in
the afternoon light it was golden was
stunning he was calling but apparently
decided that it wasn't gonna stick
around in time for you to see it
sorry about that for those of you that
don't know what it is it is a pearl
spotted owl it is a tiny tiny little owl
and probably around about the height of
my hand so it's sort of this little
thing that is called a killed course a
pearl spotted owl because of the
markings on its feathers obviously but
it also has two little eyes like oh I
like feathers on the back of its head so
that it you know obviously using timppa
dating from the front as well as the
back from the back as well as the front
they're not intimidating at all though
perpetually grumpy looking and now gone
are you back Craig this is not going
well we've driven around the whole of
cheater Plains I think not cheetah
blades chitwa I've we definitely haven't
driven cheetah plates please don't put
that down anyway we drove on [ __ ] wa and
we drove every Road and that was it
the only place I haven't checked the dam
and the reason that I didn't go and
check the dam is because I know that
everybody's going to go and check the
dam so it didn't make sense for me to do
that the radio is extremely quiet I did
manage to hear the updates and the
update is is that there's no updates oh
woe woe is us and now what now where
should we check somebody's checked their
already I think we're going to rattle
our way back along our remain and then
back towards Juma you better absolutely
no fortune no animals yeah all in all
going fantastically well this afternoon
let's go and find out whether James is
feeling the pressure as well
yes everything is going swimmingly well
we heard some Franklin's alarming we
sent the drone in after them now that
drone found some hot bushes and that's
about all so we don't think there was a
leopard in there and this it's quarter
Franklin it's now lying down eating it
which is possible but unlikely so we are
still looking about the place we did see
some very happy Impala they look like
they're just consumed a fool and very
scrumptious Sunday lunch without any
threat to their persons so they were all
fine that's about it really that's all I
have to report on the search for the
leopard front anyway it's the pressure
mounts so we continue our next plan is
going to be to drive towards the eastern
edge maybe up towards be fools hook
let's see what we can find there we must
of course hope that the hyena den
delivers as it has done the last few
episodes certainly that'd be good it was
very good at the rehearsal last night
you don't want of courses for the hyenas
to be there and then disappear as the
show begins apparently all the viewers
wondering what's happened to Tandy and
what the update is on her no idea the
other morning I had her of course on
quarantine clearings we followed her for
a long time now that's away from Camp 2
through towards buffers of dam which is
the northeast corner of Juma and we lost
her somewhere in the block when we had
to bring the drone back to change the
batteries we were trying to keep our
distance from her so we were following
her from the sky in some pretty thick
bush and unfortunately we didn't find
her again when we then took off and I
think that that's because she went to
ground I think she went to sleep they
under Bush for something like that as it
got hot and we just simply couldn't see
her I don't know if she's come out of
that block I haven't seen tracks nobody
else has reported tracks coming out of
that block we could have missed them
maybe there's a den there I don't
we have flown at four times though since
then or three times since then and not
to come up with anything just yet you
know you know this is the wilderness the
wilderness gives what the world wants to
give
and most depressingly of course is the
fact that david to get them to go to
he's down in the masai mara also
searching no pressure
well gems don't worry you might be
locked pretty soon neither are we lucky
where we are but when I found out a
little bit of a difference between the
drives in devourer and juma because
attempts in German gets the guys there
sharing information when they spot
something in tomorrow for us a bit
difficult because our radios we don't
share our frequency with anybody else it
becomes good a challenge unless
basically you meet someone on whoa Wow
Wow once one more is that silo sorry to
rush you there but that looks like a
little dog looking attentively could you
a joke oh don't go away stay there dr.
Park Jocko Oh silver box joke if you
like it's pretty good I haven't seen a
thing
dog leash or cottage the whole afternoon
but this we're very proud of a sativa
we're still holding herself a tree not
sure why he she is running alone I'd
have guessed she could be having a
button or some well we know them to be
monogamous going to 'z was like looking
for some chicks or eggs in the grass
there that's what she could be looking
for but definitely the other mid he's
not very far from there so see how lucky
is disappearing the grass there and you
would imagine how it would be for the
Lions or the leopard it steve-o cheetahs
it could be very tricky well mother why
didn't she keep moving on and make use
of the best of the lights we have now I
have come out of the area I was looking
for the sausages what I'm doing I'm
heading to the area that was bad
recently by the camp Rangers because he
is quite short indefinitely even from a
kilometer away I should be able to
see a cut now this particularly I am
going there it because as I say the
grass is short but this a lot of game
once the grass is burnt
it's intense our cylinder is come fresh
grass shoots up and it tends to attract
a lot of game and you know zebras
trapeze buffalos in that particular area
and I'm thinking maybe the cities might
go to that particular area
so what I'm trying to chance is find out
if the associates might try and go and
push the oh he knows for one purpose of
foods no because I'm going to the short
grass let's go to the long grass with
Stephen he's Leopard
yes we are following him it is not easy
work but it's a lot easier than
following lipids and jumik and tell you
that we're just hoping that there's no
big hole in the ground because this area
does have the potential to get very very
water locked but we haven't had rain for
a few days at least another little
another little bump in the ground he's
going to use it so he's come all the way
from the escarpment all the way far to
the back and left that's how far we've
been following him and we've been
working very hard to stay abreast with
him you come out of it earlier it's been
time out there's a black belly busted is
being very brave just flew directly over
his head he did that's what to skate on
but something was very exciting just
before as we're following him a grouse
owl took off out of the grass and then
landed off to the side he didn't see it
James didn't even see it but a very very
nice bird there I think it's a grass are
ours that nest in the ground they are
endangered in South Africa because of
the developments that happen
everyone whenever there's a grass he
patcher a proper natural piece of bush
in the high felt that gets kind of
plowed or turned into office blocks or
accommodation the grass are is very very
endangered in South Africa I'll see if I
can show to you I don't know if we get
the same our up here be very good if we
can there's lots of owls
excuse me while I just go through Maya
there we go African cross Sal it is the
same guy I did see him he is one of
those are sort of earless he had
toughness sort of owls that there's a
nice picture of him
sitting on the nest and their nest David
to be very cool to see you and I'd love
to show you one but it landed up and
landed in the grass again and there's no
way to get close enough to try and film
it without really influencing it's a
sort of lifestyle so we're just going to
leave it be but we see them often on the
way home at night on the road there's
owls in the road and I think it's this
guy they don't stick around for very
long but the beautiful sort of open face
they use all of that face area for full
hearing and they regard the the
toughness owl so they don't show those
visible ear tufts not that the ear tufts
are actual ears anyway
many people reckon the ear tufts are all
about sexual recognition or major
recognition in certain species very good
well everybody I'm not sure if mo was
asking to link there we're gonna stay
with some our lipids but something is
happening down in Juma which is quite
exciting Sydney has been working hard of
course he has so the pressures been
alleviated a little bit they I'm not
gonna say anything until I'm asked to
send you to Sydney and then I'm sure he
can tell you or show you where he's been
working and what successes his head so
this is kind of our afternoon we're
going to be following the shepherds
female through here we're hoping is
going to catch a water or something and
put it up a beautiful tree like this one
over here but until he does that it send
you down at ood rumor itself with
certainly formal Adam cause see for the
good news
you can see that we are very lucky we've
got Kalama who has just been drinking
here by the treehouse dam after we were
called by the kudos and the impalas in
the squealers about the presence of
Kalambo look at her Columbus looking
gorgeous and I can see that she is
indeed growing very quickly look at that
very long tail and there she's going now
towards that direction I'm just gonna
wait and see what her intentions are
this is lovely if it was not because of
the alarm course I was not going to see
her she's looking hungry maybe she will
be doing some hunting
so Kalama is one of those cats who has
been doing hunting from the young age
normally the case they learn how to hunt
went above 18 to 22 month but she
started doing hunting while she was
still very young so you can see tandy
has been a very good teacher
Tandi is their mother columbus just
about 16 to 17 month old now thank you
very very much for all the positive
comments about the finding of Columba
so I can see that she's concentrating
and here we went past Illya
there was a hyena drinking and she likes
to come to me because of the vest I
don't want to lose Kurama this is an
ornament so I'm going to carry on now I
followed in Columbus I can see she's
moving towards that direction and I
don't want to lose her she is going nice
and slow she didn't drink too much maybe
she doesn't want to get a lot of weight
she wants to do some hunt maybe who
knows we might witness something
interesting here
I can see she is now going through the
sick bushes so I'm gonna have to slowly
keep for a whipping she's right here in
front of us is just that now when the
bush is now starting to get dry she's
getting camouflaged but now while we are
repositioning we are going to cross over
to Jamie
Bravo Sydney Bravo Oh relief relief
there's slightly less panic this is good
news of course the problem is is that
she's as difficult as a mother to keep
up with in fact possibly even more so at
times so good luck to Sydney we'll keep
our fingers crossed and hold our thumbs
and all those bizarre things that human
beings do for luck in the meantime I
found a dove I'm ready to show you that
up because that's gonna just fly away
there it is look see there goes found it
dove I'm doing a boundary patrol around
Juma in this vague hope that I'm going
to see something coming on to Juma
having failed at Udrih I'm gonna draw
all the way around and then back towards
the hyena den as we sort of reach the
end of the evening that's my plan for
now I'm somewhere on the eastern edge of
Juma I don't actually know exactly where
I am all I can see those the lion tracks
from where they cut through and wound up
on Torchwood
the good news is is that now that it's
winter means that our signal vastly
improves on Torchwood when we can go
there so we'll be able to spend a bit
more time there now once the foliage
dies back and it's beautiful
everything's gold and colored is the
mythical land of Torchwood
everything's golden colored and
absolutely stunning so it's lovely to be
out and about
and we'll see what else we can find I've
got a suspicion that ting Ghana is
somewhere on Juma on a very big kill
with a very round belly alright we've
got how many of us are there out there's
Steve David James myself Sydney all
right so two out of two out of three
doing pretty well and hits go across to
David and find out if he's going to be
the third well we have just supported
something here we don't know what's
running the grass there I can't see it
very well well there's a jackal is with
a white still just disappeared in the
grass and it was chasing on a ruby it's
quite a distance see we're gonna stop
I'm not sure what that he looks like a
caribou at one point just disappearing
in the grass there it's just even before
we can be able to see it it looks like a
car approached me I don't know what
everything it was I know that every
search
yeah I'd be very happily listen
gentlemen you give an idea what do you
think that was I drove him you had a
chance to see it I would just try to
look on my monitor
but a switch job and it looks like a
check watch one point it looks like a
carrot court another point so ladies and
gentlemen
so ladies and gentlemen if you could be
able to help me identify what we serve
run in the grass fair hushed up Safari
live on Twitter I'll be very help very
happy just came running and antelope
came out of the grass
also went running and everything just
disappeared now she has gone in this
direction also they can catch up with
her and find out exactly what that was
it's very possible sets traps chuckles
very possible estate it could be some
sort of jackhole we really see them we
got them in the Mara alia humans are
gone here you also we had the black box
with a silver box Jocko
so Ashley very good Ashley let's keep
that I say things through as a character
and then we have all sort of the guest
it was a voice it killed Jocko so let's
keep those two if maybe return from here
this was either a white-tailed Jocko or
a caracal let's see if we're gonna see
her from here because that was very
strange just either a caracal white tail
or other side strap joke oh sorry side
says trapped charcoal and not white tail
Jocko or science trapped the moon goes
are the one should be watched till the
moon goes so it was either size traps
Jocko coal car is still running there I
think thick you see Manu um I'm looking
at yeah things head strapped charcoal
it's a big tree there it's right behind
the tree yes that tree there good god
Emma no yes that one there I think this
could be a side stripes Jocko
she'll the hotel there it should be
I haven't seen one for ages
what's that so I think this one must be
the voice you know it's trapped Jocko
with the white tail soon as you can
catch up with her let's see if we can
get a fresh dose
quite shy they really we really see that
they also really see our trucks of
vehicles that's why he seems to be on
the run
let's see we got a tan from here you can
get a place to cross this particular
lager here
ah-ha-ha-ha says stripes Jocko have not
seen one for donkey's years
hmm need to get a place here where we
can cross the confidence are you ready
for this okay guys hold on Mary
yeah it's very cool to see a sidestep
Jocko would you've not seen for a very
very long time
now one more place Eh close we just have
to be careful
yes our more you write lots of far older
tomorrow there
hold on yes no you're right a little bit
far on huh so if that's the case this is
sort of the type of job that you called
the golden jet boat we don't have the
video davara the golden jackal but to be
a very convinced now that was the inside
strap Jocko see we can catch up with her
she went in this direction to be very
exciting if we see her because it is
donkey's years since I is so on the
black box is silver but Jeff of ours
there
let me try and do that way the meantime
we'll take you back to Sydney with
salamba this is Martin just hold for a
second so you can see her there she is
she's keeping running stops Luke's are
you hunting there
don't you catch so many insects oh
there's a tree on the way there
she disappeared in the grass so what
you'll do go to try and catch up with
her again in the meantime we'll take you
back to two lumber with Sydney
Kalama is showing some interest maybe
she is hungry a little bit we saw she
was now trying to stalk something
unfortunately we couldn't manage to see
what she was up to but she's right here
in front of me and she is going very
much slow at the moment I am not seeing
any mood at the moment she is pretty
relaxed so the thing is that the lepers
can just be opportunistic when they are
walking and more biting like this if
anything presents itself they take
action
so from here where I am I can see maybe
we're gonna see her nicely she is right
in the middle of those glasses you can
see the white chip of the tail and the
shape right in those grasses she's not
just moving she's listening so but
considering the size of the Tommy I can
tell that she's not that heavy size
showing she must be hungry
so we're just going to
so what we are following Columbo and see
what she's up to let's cross over back
to the masai mara where Steve is waiting
well everybody how picturesque is that
I'm just gonna keep quiet for a moment
and let you let it all just sink kidness
James Pan's outs laughs and just shows
you the wonderful backdrop that we have
here in the Mara
James is waving his hands in a conductor
like manner
there's gorgeous everybody there's lots
of little noises in the background just
after you left us before we nearly
barreled into a big mud wallow had to
skirt quite a big band of them
unfortunately doesn't matter how
powerful your vehicle if you fall into
one of those holes that is the end of
you have to round cuckoo
what Brad Google it's just on top of the
Torchwood tree there wonder if you can
get him James might have the roof and
there we go
there he is they call the rained bird in
South Africa dnevnik called rain Birds
up here yeah and you get the virtual
Schuylkill very good one it seems like
the lipids are all posing for us this
afternoon let's go down and see what a
gorgeous picture the lumber makes what a
beautiful sight you can see Columba is
indeed interested on something she was I
think they surprised by the Capitol calf
who just flew away and surprised her and
you can see she is still having a lot of
interest on the Dove unfortunately to
catch dove is not an easy exercise yes
these kinds of cats they can be able to
do that but already Columbia has been
supported by the Dove so it is now
gaining at least a little bit of good
sighting from the termite mound as she
is much higher and she can see lower and
the devil flew somewhere from there
don't get surprised there are some other
vehicles coming to join me at the moment
when hearing the engines and some other
people talking
yeah takes antics incoming yeah you can
go south you can go south I'm just on
the other side of your vehicle so I'm
very sure the other beds here in this
area are not too sure about the presence
of kellerman other animals this year as
well are so very much quiet
so you can see the color of this lab has
they do play a very important role when
they are hunting so this leopard is so
come off lady would look at that now is
oh they say what are coming they say
water coming there was a big water
coming now
and this work just went past that is
what he was trying and I'm very sure
that what talk was very much bigger than
Kalam I don't think Kalam was gonna
survive day it was a very big warthog so
that works what rock just went past the
front side of Salama
so right there where she's looking at
the moment is where the white oak went
to us so the Flies must be irritating
here I can see now I'm going to carry on
following and see if we can improve this
sighting I am NOT going to leave colaba
this is an amazing sighting I haven't
seen Kalama for quite a long time
Ian something you must know is that the
leopards are solitary and they don't
hunt as a group so a warthog is way much
bigger than Kalama Columba is still very
much young that's what rock which went
past day I could see the tusks and the
size of the hares and the size of the
body that was going to be too dangerous
to tackle so that was going to be very
much dangerous for Talon battery checker
so it's a llama at the moment is moving
down towards this side it is not a easy
area to drive I'm going to take it slow
and keep following
well good luck the sitter's I do hope he
managed to keep up with her she is
tricky sometimes she takes after her
mother
but it is the Predators off to new now
it seems as a black shouldered cart has
just flown into our scene and can't
really see it from that picture but
they've got very red eyes and yellow
feet with a yellow SIA and probably one
of the most common of the birds of prey
on the African continent the black
shouldered quite very easily recognized
sometimes out in the open fields by the
way that they seem to hover above the
ground with a white underbelly and just
little black tips on the end of the wing
very very commonly found across the
African continent and they search for
rodents the way that they hover above
the ground some people believe that they
can actually see a sort of a heat
signature left by urine trails on the
ground if by rodents that are running
around these fields and in these
thickets leaving urine trails and then a
kayak will sort of hover above the
freshest sort of markings and then
dive-bombed down to latch whatever
rodent it might be but now it's actually
quite interested in our leopard moving
down and delivered and going what are
you doing over here sir all of you I
agree with you they're very pretty bird
often I haven't really seen many in room
up and we don't have the opener spaces
required for them they like open areas
where there's lots of grass and open
grasslands because obviously that's
where the rodents occur and they can see
them
saying they don't occur in the woodland
but very hard to see urine trails upon
the ground when there's trees all over
the place don't you think indeed well
what a beautiful for you he's actually
starting to clean himself now he's
finally realized that it's time to wake
up he just had a look at a Franklin that
just flew overhead he's even thinking
would that be a nice meal to have
gorgeous scenes as the Sun sets in the
background gorgeous scenes indeed
temperatures dropped quite a bit now so
you'd think this would be the moment
that he would be moving around he's been
moving in the heat of the day try Rosie
one of her flippers eat birds they most
certainly do so why we find so many
leopards and drew macaws of guinea fowl
and Franklin alarm calling and they will
very very readily catch birds we we
probably don't see it as much as we'd
like to
they'll also catch squirrels we
obviously don't see that a lot but
squirrels scrub is and sort of game
birds like Franklin's guinea fowl spear
files all form a very good part of lipid
diet
we just don't find them you know you
find a kill a daycare and then pilots
being there for a day or two in the
scrub here and he lasts about 10 minutes
or so game bird maybe the same or maybe
even less so how many do they go through
in a day it's very hard to say if they
can catch them we do know down and Rumer
how many times have I found a leopard
because of a bird alarm calling many
many many times
they get a very upset when they see a
limpid and generally when they're shot
she'll even their shot at the lippert
that Jenny had left learned for the most
part they are Gigi's down on the south
searching for the sausage tree pride I
wonder if maybe there'll be some alarm
calls given maybe there'll be some
buffaloes running around who knows and
what will happen with the sausages
well looks very true our Sivan Paul with
the help I can tell you I would have
found my sausages by now but it's very
quiet where we are not as many votes
that could make harem cause of course
I've been seeing a few or to call the
white bellied go away but which are
quite important when it comes to making
Island homes I've been seeing us a bit
of Feud rumbles but all of them are just
you know fitting and doing the thing
drongos feeding on insects are the white
weight go about feeding on the fruit
from the trees
any alum call anything that I think
could help me of where I am currently
would be the guinea hens or the guinea
fowls if our guinea fowls in such an
area because it would be out eating
grass I can now I could trust them if we
could mix up our cover as yet haven't
seen any guinea fowl and hopefully see
some I'm still very hopeful that you'll
see the sausages but again as I said
what I've done or what I did is to leave
the actual territory for the sausages
and got the boundary between them and
another pride that we call the winners
because that belongs the owners of the
winner territory is grass is bad and it
has a lot of what we call Plains game
planes game I'm talking about choppy's
impalas harvest or what you call from
gurney and maybe even some zippers and
the spinner is why either all those true
price could be here
you know the five in number and the
sausages are always about how many the
sausages are always fifteen out say it
will count the five females at the ten
cups that makes 15 and they work all the
tumors about 2017 so they have the
capacity to push the or winners little
out of their area you must have seen
some guinea hen so Guinea about some
guinea fowl Thank You Maru see the bars
I was talking about
you remember you speak of the devil I
spoke over some guinea fowls if this
bars good
Chile Chile that kind of a lab car will
be a good sign not the Franklin's that
we are here in the background so let me
keep pushing on before I lose some
beautiful daylight and chance on there
now or we nose and the meantime I'll
take you back to Sydney with Salaam
so you can see that her Columba is one
of those beautiful and clean cats she is
now busy grooming herself you can see
that is how the cast normally cleaned
himself the no more a leak their front
legs and then cleaned their eyes and the
face something has just happened here we
nearly lost her because she just jumped
and tried to dive on something maybe it
was a Franklin or something we couldn't
see what exactly she tried to grab but
she tried to catch something here a few
minutes ago I don't get surprised the
some other vehicles coming to join me at
the moment solitary life is not easy
because these animals they've got to a
hunt and follow the animals just by
themselves and catch and again is a huge
responsibility to drag animal up into
the trees so what Columbo must have to
be very careful and target missing too
that the bush is talking those are the
Franklin's so this kind of of prodigious
small predators like Kalama they must
have to consider a size before taking
down an animal otherwise it is going to
be just a fruitless exercise because the
other big predators who does scavenge
from other predators such as the eilers
if they cannot manage to take their kill
up into the tree
they are obviously going to lose that so
they got to be very much careful and
target something small so that they can
eat and finish or else they must have to
target something they can drag up into a
tree at the moment is difficult to a
tell the favorite prey food Kalama
Columba still very young the young
animals they get fascinated by anything
anything that comes their way they want
to tackle each they want to prove a
point
so it's very much too difficult at the
moment to tell this
preferences of Kalama she even tries
quitters times he climbs trees trying to
get the squealers as well but he is very
interested to tackle big games such as
the impalas so you can see she's
blending with the surrounding behind the
tambuti trees so I am going to
reposition now and keep following and
see what is going to come out so now we
are experiencing some technical
difficulties and it's apologies for the
inconvenience we'll be back soon
welcome back everybody we do apologize
for whatever technical issues have been
tackling the system the gremlins on a
Sunday afternoon I'm afraid what can you
do well the shippers Gmail is a stall
perched atop the tallest termite mound
in the entire valley and that's not very
big at all and he hasn't moved since we
last saw you so yes still said to me
he's looking a little bit sleepy now
actually after his mammoth sort of walk
and he's been doing in the heat of the
day but maybe he just knows he's gonna
have a nap just before our TV show
starts he's going to give us a very big
bellow of a leopard sawing and then he's
going to hunt himself something won't
that be wonderful nothing that would be
marvelous anyway let's quickly go down
to Columba and Siddhas
we are just keep following calamba who
is now coming down towards this
direction we might be lucky and see her
at any time
she is coming down this way in the thick
bushes here it's not easy but I can see
that she is right here at the moment
I can see she is right on a termite
mound here next to us so now let's go
back to David who is good the lion hunt
in Masai Mara
el Buffalo and it's not going to be very
easy who knows what will happen
well thank you Sydney ladies and
gentlemen things are getting a bit
better here as I told you I give up -
what it was doing idea but let's have a
look at this for a couple of seconds
before I keep talking no just like Steve
who have the Shepherd's severed female
leopard here we got a chef a tree we
were a huge rock which could a copy we
got buffalo and also we got a print of
layers that we call the oils I do not
want to interfere with this particular
hunt but I think something cool is
happening here ladies and gentlemen
there's a sternum and the buffalos or
the Buffalo is just about on say three
meters away from the Lions and the Lions
have climbed the rock so let's have a
look of what's going to happen here
listen gets my four-wheel drive gonna
crush some tight spots here all the
ladies in German man hold on
we just spin it you want it on all right
brother okay they don't we'll just talk
but something very interesting here now
we don't want get very close but there
there's a buzz Katrina struggle is
general what's happening there
sorry the trees musketry and lipids and
the Rangel's are going the Buffalo watch
they don't may want to do is to tell
this guy
yes let's cover more audience
hello hello Jambo Jambo ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to this very
special sighting that we got here
there are three lionesses here and the
trying to hunt this one very huge male
Buffalo and the climbing on that rock
that look big or trying to intimidate
him and let's see what a good husband
ladies and gentlemen we in a country
called Kenya we in the Masai Mara Game
Reserve the marked Wrangler specifically
my name is David and I'm come with me is
Manu welcome unless here this particular
epic moment together now I have counted
three layouts here on top of that rock
and one male buffalo big tree that you
see there is called Bosque a tree and
let's see how things are going to turn
out this particular pride of lions I
know it and we call it the OE no tried
it composes of five layers in turtle
what am I saying for females and one
youngster Mel well bring down a buffalo
is not easy but they are determined and
to me okay they're very ambitious to do
this I haven't seen them I bring down a
buffalo this could be the day so
currently there's a standoff the Lions
are making a move the buffalo is not
making a move we'll find out who will
make the fast wing here and I'm happy
that all of you are saying this is
pretty exciting and not sure I want the
Buffalo dead but also I do not want the
Lions to go hungry now this is one of
the lionesses and I'm thinking what they
want to do is just to traumatize him you
know I psychologically torture him and
maybe he'll keep going round and round
and when darkness will come they might
decide to pounce on him
they can good question you'd like to
know where they are the Buffalo the
other the other lions are I'm gonna say
Thalia is right has five so I just got
here I would seriously three five
minutes ago and I've seen the three so
we'll find out we are the other two are
because I highly doubt the three can
bring this Buffalo down as much as it's
very possible let me just give money
better I'm going up as you see how
things will turn out to be okay stop
there Jemma how are you and I'll tell
you Gemma without any contradiction or
fear or any doubt the sausages are the
specialist of bringing down buffalos all
we know is not that I don't trust them
but they do not have the experience they
do not have the skills the sausages have
now three lions against one huge male
Buffalo if it was a female maybe a
little different a little smaller and it
could be a lot easier for them but as it
is now they always tend to zero in on
the male Buffalo that's left behind in
hard or in a group and they found this
one look at that it looks like a joke I
mean that huge tree or those two trees
there let you cross the boss scared
trees the buffalo in the meadow Health
Alliance which I would say they're
basically three meters about three years
away from that buffalo now this is know
that the Buffalo cannot climb that rock
that they know for a fact and they know
they're very safe where they are and the
Lions will not come down because what
would happen is the Buffalo might had
them roughly rights and this lands look
hungry I do not remember the last time
they came for a hunt and I'm wondering
where the other two members are because
if you're the two members are it could
be a lot easier and what's happening let
me just back up because there's one
that's looking
behind there and either she is looking
at the other member of the pride and if
his true what I'm thinking is the other
men of the fight because she has kept
looking in that particular direction for
a long time
then we shall have fall and maybe find
out oh yes I think I'm right
not even one the other two of them are
coming and what will happen is in that
one and that other one there
now we're talking of four females and we
are going to have five lions and one
lever so let me just move for a little
bit and one Buffalo so that you can have
a better angle for all of us to see what
will happen this is very excitingly I
wanna let me know whether I'll give you
good angle
are you saying this is a brave Buffalo
but tell you Hana you took me on five
layers against one Buffalo and let's
find out on the arrival of the other two
Hana I'll tell you one thing the
ballgame is definitely going to change
chances are this Buffalo might go down
five against one out three on top of
that rock and you can't see too slowly
and surely coming up to reinforce the
other three and wow this is really
something and you still can see the
beautiful the savanna of the Mara
triangle open grass so that is the mail
boy there is the youngster meal and I'm
not sure what he's saying
with his tail as he's moving it and a
lot of other things are going on in his
head attitude the other two females have
arrived and for those of you who are
joining us now this particular pride is
called a winner pride and they're trying
to bring down these male Buffalo of
course the experience doesn't mean they
can't do it I'm sure they have done it
before I haven't personally see it but
this could be the day I'm witnessing oil
witness a buffalo hunt from the owner
pride
Jane is it looks pretty young and maybe
inexperienced I agree with you totally
but now we have the full squad we have
the whole team of the winners five of
them together one Buffalo someone is
looking for dinner and someone doesn't
want to die often nobody will get
disturbed by this but as it is now it is
so far so good but should you get little
bit of motion on this one I might maybe
request you to either change your screen
or do something else but here we're
looking forward for five lions seriously
and badly wanting to get some dinner
because I haven't had or I don't
remember the last time they got a kill
for themselves
look at that stand of there the Buffalo
two eyes against ten eyes that you know
what you are not going to bring me down
so the only one thing the Buffalo will
not do is start going to leave here
because the moment he leaves he knows
these lions are going to hug him from
the behind they're gonna pull him down
and it will be very easy to kill him -
what he wants to do is to show them I
can see you do not play any games and as
I said earlier what they may want to do
is to wait for darkness to come in and
either one or two might you know slowly
sneak on him from the back and when
he'll turn around the others maybe will
jump on his head or the neck and then
choke him well ladies and gentlemen what
you've done now is to go to infrared
just to make sure that we do not retain
any bright lights on them let's go back
to our kill there or rather to a hunt
and this is very very special infrared
how it says ladies and gentlemen to see
Dan was very very very easily without us
sharing any artificial light to them and
you're all saying it's pretty special
and crazy to watch I can't believe this
it could take minutes it could take
hours before a decision is made when
let's go
can you see how is not him
and I hope you can all hear how he's
snorting trying to can you hear the
ladies and gentlemen
now one of the lead females in this
particular pride is called butternut
she's the oldest and she's the most
experienced one so as I said here
there'll be a lot of brain games here a
brain of heads and seeing who turns fast
as I said they want to maybe torture him
as much as possible and psychologically
wear him out but of course once his turn
he may easily like lose concentration
and maybe one of them or two of them
will jump on him and try and hug him to
the ground
Lisa treu incidence ISA one just jumped
Lisa you know it might be getting beat
you know just taking off it's running
they're all after him
they keep so close to the car they owe
after him so we're gonna trade you two
okay
taking him he's just jumping on him now
so let's just get so close
even here stop here for seconds and the
old surrounded him now ladies and
gentlemen everybody has taken a
commercial break but I can see something
happening here they're trying to wear
him down
he is alone he can call for help he
won't go verify he looks a bit too worn
out that was really real crazy ladies
and gentlemen and the line is because
they're 5 so why don't we jump on him
while the other four are having a break
he's trying to fight back and this is
how Kingston was hardly there is one
that has jumped on top of him on the
back hall in tight he's nothing let him
go he's holding tight let's see what
here the four will do the red can we
give a hand he's pulling down
I know he might be calling for help now
when you hear that he's there trying to
call you the members oh he's had but the
one at the bar is holding very very
tight money do want to move for a little
bit I think it's just about tapas in
general and he's going wall and that's
what they do when the opponent when they
want to call the other members to come
for help
going down easily it's really fighting
back it's moving up and down taking them
round and round
now we could - or in the back I gotta
stop here who are these three on the way
and I think that is in German it's
happening I gotta stop here I don't want
get very close and one is holding on the
leg and ladies and gentlemen I'm just
keeping quiet I'm right here but I think
it could be as well as almost game game
up and this o winners have done themself
a very good job first time I'm seeing
the arenas hunting and if you carefully
listen gentlemen they're doing
everything possible to avoid the homes
wow this is very epic ladies and
gentlemen very special as I might have
said before should any one of you be
disturbed by this setting you may do
something else it's a bit dark ladies
and gentlemen because of course it has
gotten dark where we are but so long as
I'm happy you can still see it and what
one of them is doing is just holding the
test cause of the male Buffalo because
they know once they pull that is one
particular part to give it's a lot of
pain oh definitely
it's almost time for him to go and in
the background ladies and gentlemen we
got some zebra Steve look carefully as
much as you look stuck there
zebra Slayer and maybe the debating if
they can give any help definitely not
we hope it's not the day so what I want
you is for a little [ __ ] ladies and
gentlemen again
I would see them want to interfere with
this particular hunt and wow this is
really something
how special is this so one of them is
holding the tail and the other one is
holding the test cause it's a Dahlia and
the other one is holding the honest
that's a very soft patch patch ladies
and gentleman this is such a big battle
what Robin you say this is a very sad
moment well ladies and gentlemen this is
pretty very special I mean we did not
expect this to happen and how cool was
that
or how cool has this been thank you so
very much for having joined us don't go
away we continue broadcasting on the
YouTube you can keep following us but
for now for me and my new many thanks
and goodbye well ladies gentlemen
welcome back what I want to do now
because this hand quarters of got what
you're going to do we're going to put
our IR or infrared rights on in the
meantime let's take you very quickly to
Steve
how's everybody what an interesting
encounter that is indeed thankfully we
have got Wi-Fi on the car so Sam's now
been sitting watching that unscheduled
broadcast as well
how incredible via we know prior to
doing what they do and as David as David
said first time he's seen him hunting I
saw them last year taking down a couple
for the Beast which was so so special
but Buffalo is a very different kettle
of fish
isn't it well done a weiners well
obviously that's going to continue on is
probably going to go on for hours we are
still going to be here with our male
leopard and well what perfect timing for
a TV show on a Sunday evening for
sapphire life and we got a male leopard
Sydney I think is still with salamba and
there we know pride out of nowhere
tackles a buffalo
so that is very very interesting
thankfully our sausage tree sausage a
shepherd's tree mail has not moved he is
set in the same spot as you left us with
him earlier so it's allowed us to also
take a little bit of downtown because he
has been making us a work or afternoon
and some were there in the distance is
where David and man who are we could see
their light earlier and they're not far
away from us as the crow flies but from
my side it is a good night I hope you
have a beautiful one but over to David
and Manu who have got all lights on the
action well ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to this very special
setting ladies and gentlemen where they
I'm just keeping quite for you to hear
how the Buffalo is making his last cause
of life and I highly doubt he got any
chance of survival
the arena's have gotten themselves on
dinner so he's just calling for help now
well ladies and gentlemen what a lovely
Saturday afternoon and on behalf of all
my plebs signature Lamba
Steve the leopard and me with his hunt
remember again to join us tomorrow
morning many thanks and on behalf of
everybody thank you again and goodbye
[Music]
[Music]